20 years later and oops I did it again
it is well doing it again it's been so
fast you know like I feel like I just
started yesterday to celebrate the
monster hits anniversary on May 16th
Britney Spears is releasing a remixes &
b-sides EP on baby blue vinyl this is a
story about a girl yep oops
lucky stronger and don't let me be the
last to know are all getting the remix
treatment and for rare songs will be
included as well it's gonna be hot
the limited edition pressing is part of
2020s Record Store Day lineup and will
be available at participating locations
hi 80 I'm Britney Spears we were with
Britney the day her iconic album dropped
in 2000 because I've put so much into it
you know what I mean and I like it
myself so much and I just want everyone
else to you know take it as well it
would sell 1.3 million copies in its
first week and go on to be certified
diamond with 10 million albums sold in
America alone there's been so much
leading up to this you know it's like oh
my god it's actually here it's
definitely more me I have to say it's
the album basically is talking about
just you know being yourself and being
happy with you and not caring about what
other people think like one of the
titles of the songs is what you see is
what you get and you know it's I think
it's cool it's a good message for
teenagers out there they're just
stronger and they have more attitude
they're edgy err
[Applause]
[Music]
eighteen year old Brittany was in New
York for appearances on TRL and Saturday
Night Live the one about my boobs being
fake that is just ridiculous I went out
the other night after SNL and then I'm
two days before that I went out to just
you know have that release me with your
friends and have fun you know oh god
yeah dance
so we hours in the morning and actually
the next day I had in TV live thing that
I had to do and I'm just like this so
tired I got like two hours of sleep but
it was fun it was fine it was worth it
know what you think my luck changes from
week to week Britney was riding high
after the success of her debut baby one
more time
[Music]
the crowds reaction and when I see them
you know loving the songs and actually
knowing that words to the songs that's
the best feeling in the world you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I do Oh totally it's not really like
I get nervous it's just like this
adrenaline inside and it's just you
can't wait to get out there
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so focused on the music right now
I'm really busy with my music this is I
really want to concentrate on that
especially after the tour concentrating
on the next album I really wanted to
bring that to the next level she
definitely brought it and even caught
the eye of Madonna who wore this shirt
after the release of oops I think she
saw me where when I first shirts one
time
you know like tributes to me she wanted
to do the same thing and in a short
period of time
Britney went from fangirl with Alan
she's had like four rows in front of me
and I was the person that was singing I
was like oh man that's what I know I was
like freaking out but I didn't get a
chance to meet him - up close and
personal with the Material Girl you know
what this is seriously something I've
dreamt about since I was a little girl I
cannot believe this just like freakin
happened
[Applause]
big deal now maybe we're talking like
you used to be so innocent and that I'm
like when I was doing maybe one more
time you guys were complaining it just
be yourself and whatever and just enjoy
the music
[Music]